[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i know how to get you rattled nobody
could rattle you like me i'd rather you
were you there that night where joe
rogan went to the strip club
no
oh
cause joe rogan didn't talk to me for
years after that
because he was headlighting and then we
went we went to a stripper i thought you
were there and then there was these gang
members with tattoos on their faces i
didn't know anybody i was young and
jokes let's get out of here and we're
with other comics i thought you were
there and i go no don't be a [ __ ]
right because they were like eyeing us
and stuff and then years later i had to
apologize to joe i go i know we almost
died
i'm sorry
all right i i feel funny i gotta get out
of
here
i feel dizzy or something man not like
that that's nice yeah yeah have some
water like it was just fine yeah i drank
it nothing happened i have some red bull
nothing happened after the day i have
some red bull and some water how's that
earlier i said that i sucked a guy's
dick did i say that yes you did okay
that's okay nothing wrong with that i
feel like it's been weird ever since
then no no what was what was worse the
dick or [ __ ]
what [ __ ] like when you're just
licking a girl's [ __ ]
i they dick for sure
i'm not gay dude
yeah but i was thinking about it the
other day have you ever sucked a dick no
you've never nope not even once no you
would think about it
but i was i was thinking about a couple
like last week for girls it just must be
like
hard skin like that's all like it
doesn't what like it doesn't it doesn't
taste like anything like if you take a
jacket that's why you should try it
when does this air by the way this is
tomorrow i'm going to be at portland
where helium when this weekend oh [ __ ]
that's one of my favorite [ __ ] clubs
i love that club yeah i taste them they
used to have potato dots yeah now you
know i hate ranch dressing right yeah
but these [ __ ] took it to the
next level what do they put in there
they put that scala machi korean sauce
what's that
it's not korean
chinese
yeah
is chinese yeah man thank you very much
what's it called sriracha sriracha it's
chinese yeah when you text me your
address the other day yeah i'm not gonna
repeat it yeah
i i go i know this street
i just don't know where it is and when i
looked it up i go this is my old cook
dealers tree
he used to stay open until two
so i really like this house this is yeah
yeah he had business hours
three hours eleven a.m oh wow that's a
long hour he would get drunk from four
to seven so you couldn't call him he
never sell coke from four to seven yeah
but his tip top hour and then he then he
shortened my curfew until one
if you don't have no cash it's one wow
if you got cash it's two if you're
fronting you got to a one
i would leave la jolla comedy store
at a quarter to twelve yeah
and i would get right here by one whoa
whoa
i could do la jolla in an hour and 15 an
hour 20.
i'd do 90
or 80 all the way to the border yeah
where they asked you to stop for fruit
and from there to irvine i'd do a
hundred
a hundred
a hundred no registration
no insurance
barely break pads
that brings up a story
i remember one time i was in my hotel a
hotel room in san diego like by tijuana
and it was like 2 p.m i was sleeping in
this hotel room
and i get a call and they go
why are you are you at the table reed
and i was so drugged out
right because i had just gotten pills
from tijuana
i'm like i have a table read
how [ __ ] embarrassing is that
jesus i'm so drugged out i can't even
make it to a [ __ ] network table read
for sure
so i did a movie i booked a movie called
pizza and bullets
sounds great it was horrible yeah it was
horrible and they had the girl from the
godfather
but i went and shot the first scene and
i'm like i'm not going back
you were you did this and the next day i
had a 6 a.m call and i got coked up to
the gills yeah
and they came knocking on my daughter
and i grabbed the kid threw him and [ __ ]
and they called the cops it was
hysterical oh wow don't you want to be
in this movie i'm like i never want to
be in your [ __ ] movie again the
casting director called me and said he'd
never book me again
call everybody [ __ ] pizza tell him that
i was a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah and
the director called me and i yelled at
him and now the director's trying to be
my friend on lincoln then [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him i don't even have lincoln but i
saw his name i'm like look at this
[ __ ] creepy dude do you believe do
you believe in karma yes i do i've lived
it i'm living proof of karma yeah but
can i ask you something then
though how come like um
like guys like george w bush nothing bad
happens to him something bad happens to
him we just don't know it
no he's playing golf and stuff something
bad happens to him every day when he has
to face himself at the end of the night
that's when karma shows up yeah but he
like started a bunch of illegal wars and
a lot of people died and stuff right
he'll pay for it he deserves aids and
stuff at some point it's so like i
remember when i when i robbed this guy
you're never getting back into that
right now and i robbed 18 five
like what i made from the scam was 18 5.
you know what i ended up paying the
attorney 18 000. i never forget that
looking at the bills and going well you
got caught i made 500 bucks
like this is god sending me a bill like
i made fight like god making me realize
and i made 500 for two years of my life
because i know you've beaten a man with
a pipe before no no i didn't beat nobody
with nobody you know you've never beaten
anybody with a powerful dog yeah i think
you have no no no yeah yeah no no no you
told me one time that you've been a man
with a pipe i must have smacked them
with a two-by-four yeah yeah yeah right
that's a big you've never like beaten
the guy to almost dead with a pipe
before no you yes you have no i haven't
no i haven't you got the right yeah
you're the wrong guy yeah you've never
violently attacked anybody before not
with a pipe never with what
i got into fights some guy jumped me and
he had a two by four i took it from him
hit him with him one time yeah yeah i
hit a guy with a heineken bottle when i
was 18 he was a man
yeah he was a [ __ ] man you know he
was a real [ __ ] man he had another
friend that was a man and we were scared
uh
but you've never taken a pipe out of
your car and beaten a man with it i'm
taking a pipe up he got to the point i
remember one night i was over there like
at nine
i was already living with terry guys
this is when i knew this girl was crazy
and she called me one more okay you just
brew up real quick about terry when i
found out years ago that you were seeing
her i couldn't believe it yeah because
she was like the hottest waitress we had
right i go she's [ __ ] that guy
that's unbelievable i'm just so happy
that
so
yeah i mean imagine though like the
hardest one you and i are similar in
this way also is that we get like three
or four lines in a movie
you know like i remember like i watched
that movie taxi
not taxi driver but the jimmy fallon
queen latifah
right right you're in that movie yeah
right yeah and i remember going watching
the movie going
the only thing i remember is joey diaz
being in it he's so funny or spider-man
yeah you remember spider-man yeah the
first one
you were in that 14 days one line
two weeks those are the good old days
over time yeah drinking pomegranate
juice smoking dope in my green room and
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah two weeks one line
joey you're too big to be hanging out on
the train
yeah go to the green room when i booked
it it was one day yeah and then they
called me in june they go go to wardrobe
and when i went to wardrobe they're like
you start working next week i'm like
what are you talking about july 31st
they're like nah
those are the good old days
they let you sit for two days or you're
like in your trailer and you fall asleep
for like seven or eight eight hours and
you open your eyes you don't know where
you are and then you get a knock and
then some nerd we're not going to use
you too yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're like wow that was great now that
was [ __ ] great yeah lots of tales
spider-man 2 lots of light on friday and
white people still be eating salads and
apple pie i mean lobster tails to go i
got 19 lobster tails i'm shoving lots of
tail in every pocket one night i saw
i walk in the main room it's dark and i
see legs popping out
on the bot some girl's legs just
sticking out of where the booth is sort
of half her body was in the booth her
legs were saying it was pitch black
and i looked
and there was blood everywhere and she
tried to kill herself in there
jesus
okay and i'm gonna name you who it is
but she was she was a waitress
this had to be 18 years ago a long time
ago i still remember who that was yeah a
long time ago
she tried to kill herself over a manager
yes a black man yeah
yeah yeah yeah now let me tell you how
this story even gets quite geekier i
like that girl very much not as a
boyfriend but she was very sweet
she moved out here she was taken naive
by a manager who was suave
he had like a wife or a girlfriend yeah
he's like uh but he was playing very
very swab and i saw him playing huh and
you but when we say we can just say when
when we say black he's not like
kanye black he's more no he's more jordi
know the name i i couldn't
put them on i couldn't figure out a
lineup i know i know i know i know a guy
let's let's cut i know but i'll tell you
let me tell you the story donald glover
okay you're gonna fall i don't go over
you're gonna die when you hear this okay
so
this is early on in the comedy store
career this waitress dies to kill
herself and i gotta tell you something
they [ __ ] with me because i really
liked her
and when i heard why she tried to kill
herself i never really liked that guy
anymore he disappeared
funny story about him then he popped
back
then he came back years later okay
i never said nothing it was none of my
business
you're gonna pick your battles but at
the time i'm blind i'm buying coke from
a couple of different people
i have an armenian coat dealer
i have a mexican coke dealer
i have a black coat dealer and i have
another black coat dealer now one of
those black coats this happens to be a
comedian look at my eyes i know what it
is he happens to be a comedian sl
uh he had the worst
cocaine
that you could ever imagine he was
always my last choice because i
confronted from him
he would get high and forget i even
because he was on pills
i know where you're talking he was on
pills it was the [ __ ] crate and i
liked him i liked him too he was the
worst comic in the world but i liked him
and he lived two blocks from my house
and even with all my cocaine paranoia i
could still drive to his house and get a
package he was like mcdonald's of
cocaine right so i would say to him hey
leave me some coke and your motorcycle
so he would leave his garage door open
millions of people would walk by
and in the motorcycle in the little
booth
there'd be a package waiting for me
so he would call me next day and say did
you take the package and i go no he goes
there's no money there what are you
talking about
i didn't take the package and he goes
somebody [ __ ] took the packet so this
went on for months but i always worked
things out
so it's new year's eve when i go up
there and i flip the thing open and i go
to and i hit
joey and i look up and it's that girl
that tried to kill herself
at the store 10 or 12 years earlier and
then looking like what the [ __ ] are you
doing here
because i'm waiting for her
she goes have you seen him is he
upstairs
and i felt like saying didn't you try to
kill yourself over a different black guy
yeah [ __ ] 10 years ago
and now you're another [ __ ] black guy
you want to hang yourself again whether
you want to pull up or dana go get the
[ __ ] i just walked out of there like and
i told him the next day
i called him up and i go hey man
you can't [ __ ] with that chick
you can't hold the whole story she tried
to kill herself
over some black dick before and he had a
girlfriend you you got 20 white women
that are chasing you she'll have a heart
attack i try to take her to a meeting
right because i was over
i'm driving down los cienega she jumps
out of my car
going [ __ ] 40.
i never saw her again
all i was doing
she was like thinking that i was like
some sort of human trafficker or
something she goes you you you want to
go to a meeting right and get sober it's
like i don't know much about him i go
you're going to die
so i tried to be the good dude she
jumped out of my [ __ ] car at 40 miles
an hour yeah can i tell you something
funny about that guy the manager though
so he was doing comedy too did you know
that yes for years for years
so i didn't see him for years so one day
i get a call from this guy named tony
calabrese from san diego because do you
want to judge a comedy competition in um
tucson arizona
so how am i gonna get there he goes i
have a private plane we're gonna do the
whole thing
so i fly to tucson
it's a huge comedy competition i'm one
of the judges
next thing i know this next guy's from
orlando
right he's been doing comedy for two
weeks only
ladies and gentlemen
it's the guy
the black manager
he doesn't know i'm judging
he comes up there he's been doing it for
10 years at that time
but he's trying to pawn it off like he's
on you just fart i was trying to i
didn't fight i tried to move for two for
he said he'd been doing good for two
weeks he goes up he wasn't even that
good
but then i gave him a zero
out of one out of ten okay
did you just fart you stopped starting
that's so gross dude thank you yeah you
did i heard it i did not freeze yeah
yeah it went he's actively pushing it
out did you smell it yeah i did no you
did if you don't smell it
yeah yeah i [ __ ] smell it right now
dude
it smells like cuban something
yeah it's rude dude sorry about that
yeah well you're not you keep doing it
yeah yeah yeah
relax all right
joey you
you get so emotional you got it so
emotional yeah bro we're talking this is
from the heart here this ain't no
[ __ ] okie doke podcast
i don't do podcasts
okie dokie either i know that i just
said yeah i'm real too no that's why i'm
saying it don't call me okay i love you
today i love you too now we do this
thing called unhelpful advice we'll do
it really quickly we have a email and
then we give suggestions and then we'll
end it okay go ahead unhelpful advice
with bobby kalila and joey coco diaz
my father-in-law equals amazing loving
supportive and loved seeing him always
his wife slash mother-in-law equals
attic booze pills cigarettes cigarettes
and weed for years we've uh bit our
tongues and tried to include my
husband's mother in our exciting life
milestones his dad's always there and
supportive but his mother in her
condition has added nothing but stress
and frustration to our lives events and
holidays we're now expecting our first
child and i do want i do not want her at
the hospital or even around the first
couple of weeks until i am comfortable
with the new motherhood
and if she is sober she makes me anxious
and is a mess i don't want our exciting
next chapter to have a horrible memory
of her actions like our wedding did we
do love and want my husband's father
around whenever he wants to be he's
amazing but they come as a pair quite
often how do we approach the newborn
time i would hate to rob my
father-in-law of his first moments as a
grandfather because of her actions
mimi weed around together that's a
tricky one that's not a tricky one you
go hey dad you come mom you're out
no
father-in-law's cool mother-in-law is
batshit crazy they wanna
bring dad and father-in-law for all
family festivities but not mom-and-law
but they come as a duo they don't come
as a duo well it i understand that but
the thing is is that when people think
that they come in pairs it's like
if i was in my drug addiction
right i was using and club didn't leave
and she was still she would leave but
she would definitely leave but if she
didn't leave right and then
i you were invited to a wedding and i
wasn't
i'm well aware of i'm like yeah that's
why because i'm a [ __ ] fuck-up
yeah i would i would set boundaries and
be clear about how you feel about her
that's just that's the only solution to
this well that was a great episode
[Music]
[Music]
it's a
just the wrong way
[Music]